JENNY BROWN: This
week, we're talking
about the newest Google Cloud
region, hybrid connectivity,
and the 2020 IT skills survey.
I'm Jenny Brown, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Our CEO recently announced
a new partnership
with Poland's domestic
cloud provider.
As a part of that
partnership, we're
opening a brand new Google
Cloud region in Warsaw
to bring lower latency
and higher performance
to Central and Eastern Europe.
Cloud computing solutions depend
on great networks as well as
great products.
And to help you make
your network the best,
we've graduated two
services from beta
to general availability.
100 Gigabits-per-second
Dedicated Interconnect
can scale your
connection capacity,
and High-Availability
VPN protects
your mission-critical workloads
with an industry-leading 99.99%
SLA.
The Global Knowledge 2019
IT Skills and Salary Report
gave us a comprehensive
look at industry standards,
certifications,
and compensation,
all broken down by region.
The 2020 survey is running
now through November 8.
So if you're an IT professional
and have about 10 minutes
to spare, we'd love
to hear your voice
in the largest worldwide study
of the growing IT industry.
Machine learning is all anyone
can talk about these days.
But if your co-workers
keep throwing ML and AI
around interchangeably,
please feel
free to direct them to
this lovely ML breakdown
brought to you by the
Google Comics Factory.
It's got everything
you need to learn--
solid examples, clear
expectations, and of course,
cartoon cats.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us,
and we'll see you in the cloud.